DOWN LOW  -- CENTERS IT OUT.
LOST HIS GLOVEVEYESTERDAY.
SHE IS AN EARL-- A GOOD
GAME YESTERDAY.
GOT THE PUCK -- AFTER IT.
ONSTART IN THE LAST 12
BLUES GAMES.
>> KEITH: A COUPLE GOOOOTO THE
PASTA
WELL PACED FIRST PERIOD THUS
LAWTON PREPARED A GREAT MOVE TO
JUST.
YOU SEE ATKINSON HIGH ON THAT
LIVE! HE SCORES!
THEY
>> Jim: WIND UP WITH THE PUCK .
RISTOLAINEN -- GOT IT.HE PRIOR
SEQUENCE.
THE SAME TRIO THAT COMES DOWN
THE ICE. SAID.
THERE.
PROVOROVING TAKEN DOWN BY
Jim:
ATKINSON.
ALL THE WAY ACROSS
>> THAT WAS A DANGEROUS
OPPORTUNITY, WASN'T IT?
WILLMAN --SLOWLY MAKING HIS WAY
BACK TO THE PHILADELPHIA BENCH
AF GETS IN THE WAY OF THIS
BLAST FROM WALMAN.
BOY, THAT HURT!
IT MEETS BINNINGTON.
FINALLY.
AND IT IS TIED.
TOP OF THE THOMAS.
-- THEY
RIGHT TIME.
-- A LITTLE BUMP
COULD NOT CLEAR.
VAN RIEMSDYK HAS IT.
1024 AROUND.THAT.
TO THE CORNER.
YANDLE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO GET
THERE.
KNOCKS  THTH -- WITH THE FIST IN
THE FACE OF -- BOUNCING PUPU
ATKINSON TO BARB PROVOROV.